a new episode of Sara's music is being
shot and one of the world's most famous
opera singers has come for lunch
Placido Domingo and here's another star
russian opera singer anna netrebko
they're delighted to be the guests of
French horn player Sarah Willis music
you know it is so wonderful this program
so we looking forward to make a career
and you will be interviewed by her
Sara's music is a new dawn Chevelle a
program that aims to give a fresh and
unconventional take on the world of
classical music the biggest challenges
for Sara's music for me is recording the
program in English and in German
I've lived in Germany a long time but
these articles they are d-does you never
learn it you just never learn it so that
that's a big challenge for me the other
challenge is I think for the whole team
is that we've had so much fun recording
these last episodes that there's just so
much fantastic material we don't want to
throw any of it away so to get
everything into twelve and a half
minutes that's also a big challenge
this episode is being shot in Salzburg
hundreds of thousands of music fans
flocked to the Austrian city's annual
festival every summer Sara Willis has
been here plenty of times I love being
in Salzburg we played here with the
Berlin Philharmonic for many years at
the Easter Festival and so we know every
corner and every cafe and a personal
highlight would be all the cakes in the
apple strudel in the in the cafes here
in Salzburg really amazing but dangerous
in 2001 she was the first female brass
player to make it into the renowned
Berlin Philharmonic
and so a dream came true have a long
should he atonement and pastor Denton I
studied in London and we did a chamber
music tour with some other students we
watched a rehearsal here and as I sat in
the audience and heard the sound I
thought to myself this is it this is my
ideal sound in public home I just wanted
to be near this wonderful Orchestra it's
my absolute ideale clang only forward to
I 400 near front isn't all more cast
aside but she didn't stop there she also
enjoys smaller and less conventional
venues such as nightclubs and she's also
very involved in schools in the hope of
instilling a passion for music in
youngsters
but she's also a woman of the digital
age she uses social networks like
Facebook Twitter and Google Hangouts to
promote classical music and of course
her new show and she's always doing her
best to offer a new and unusual
perspective like here at the Salzburg
Festival where Anna Netrebko
is seen singing from behind the stage
Thank You sexy mouth 19 feelings Sera's
music gives viewers a glimpse of what
goes on behind the scenes of the
classical world
motto is music should be fun if you've
had a boring music teacher at school you
grew up thinking classical music is
boring but we think it's fantastic and
I'm really happy to have this chance to
try and communicate that in a different
way with a lot of humor so stay tuned
for the next episode of Sarah's music on
DW